I'm my name is Bill emotion from mcafee
drama social entrepreneur I was just a
discussion leader in the social
innovation inspection we just had we had
a fantastic deal and lots of interesting
discussions about how to scare or social
business how to measure social impact
and we talked about the importance of
appleton social businesses solving many
of the social clubs in the world in our
central business power the most
efficient mechanisms to really solve
those rated social challenges so we had
a lot of great Marie's really impressive
lots and lots of things are leading
social businesses or admin social
business isn't a store with me leading
social businesses and it was great to
get audio but based on experience so
it's been a fantastic fantastic time for
me to be here